So,
um,
we just got to move on now and follow
up on what we talked about last time,
which is the seven fold permutation
is as kind of intimidating, um,
but it's actually what we'll be talking
about in the fall class that was devoted
to for whom devout hose.
Um,
and last time we talked a lot about
the voluntary versus involuntary
association, including, um, the idea
of the involuntary foreigners, right?
That both Americans and
the Spanish actually, um,
can be involuntary foreigners,
the Americans in the simple fact that
they don't have perfect command of the
language and also that they
are recognizable as far and as,
as outsiders in the community.
But the Spanish can also be
outsiders in their own community, uh,
because of two things because of the
print illiteracy and because of the 10 of
the logical, uh, illiteracy.
So in those two ways, um,
they are both stuck with a kind
of voluntary association. Um,
today we'll move on to the
next, uh, way to configure,
um, the contents of for whom
the bell tolls. And, um,
I'd like to think of it as a very
sustained structure. Hemingway, um,
is, uh, uh, a writer
who actually, um, keeps,
not only starts out with a pattern,
but kids elaborating on that pattern.
So in many ways it really is a kind of a
musical structure, FEMA and very Asian,
um,
and the paradigm of distant home versus
onsite environment that actually is a
theme and variation almost out the
entire for whom the bell tolls,
um,
and plugged into that is a kind of
play between the comic and the tragic.
Uh, but really the, the main,
the dominant theme today would be the
relation between distant homes and onsite
environment. Um, so I've seven
candidates for distant homes.
One is, um, in Paris, which
is very odd because you know,
already where in the foreign countries
to American readers, um, Spain, uh,
but there's yet another foreign
country of France and especially Paris,
uh, which makes a cameo appearance.
Um, and then they have five locations,
we'll spatial locations and 10 fro
locations in the United States that are
distant homes for Robert Jordan.
So we'll talk about why each of them
is involved. Um, and relation betrayal,
that distant home and the immediate
is Spanish setting. But first of all,
Perez, um, Paris comes up, um,
in the context of Robert Drinking the
abstinence that he carries with him.
Um,
and right before that he's actually asked
for wine and there's not a lot is one
left. So Maria wants to give him one.
The public says there's not much left,
so he doesn't get to have to unwind
from the, from the, just the,
from the logos. Um, and instead he
pulls out this bottle of absence.
Um, and nobody there has seen this. Um,
so he tells them that
this is Madison and um,
the Gypsy state wants to tase where
there's medicine tastes like Robert Jordan
pushed the cup to what him,
it was milky yellow now with the water.
And he hoped that Gypsy would
not take more than a swallow.
And this was very little of it left.
And one cup of it took the place of the
evening papers of all the old evenings
in cafes of all IHG has not trays that
would be in bloom now in this month of
the gray slow horses of the
outer boulevards of bookshops,
of chaos and of galleries of the pop here
of the stat about the stock buffalo of
the beauty Shamone of the
guaranty trust company. And again,
there was a day or four years,
oh hotel and being able to read and
relaxed in the evening of all the things
they enjoy it and forgotten.
And that came back to him
when he tasted that peg,
that her tone now main brain warming,
stomach warming,
idea changing liquid alchemy.
This is as beautiful praise
on to Paris as I've seen.
Um,
but what is odd about this praise Song
of Paris is that it actually is not
pointing to all the monumental,
um,
tourists attractions of Paris,
right? No Ivo Towel in there.
I know off the tree on, um,
instead it is the chestnut trees,
actually the horse chestnuts
in this picture. Um,
but chestnut trees all from
Harris v very common site.
Um, kiosk, very, very common site. Um,
hot most who he is is not really,
it's actually kind of, um,
out of the way and it's not, it's not
very spectacular. It's just a park.
Um, and then this stat buffalo,
actually, I've never, I don't eat,
I have to look it up. You might not even
be there. Um, it's a cycling tracks. Um,
and then the pop, the abuse, um,
it's also not mean it's a nice pop,
but I don't think it's that famous. Um,
is more of a kind of a neighborhood park.
It's on the hill.
So are kind of this Hillary structure.
This is the Butte that
gives the pop the name. Um,
and that year they elicit is the, uh,
island in the middle of the sand. Um,
it's very beautiful place. But once
again, this is a neighborhood rather than,
you know, kind of major tourist
attraction. Although the, um,
the Notredam Cathedral, um,
is there, um, and finally,
uh, the hotel for you, once again,
it's a, you know, as a legend.
Um,
but there's also a place that you would
just walk by every day without noticing
it.
And that's really the main
point is that all those names,
um,
this,
I don't even think it is Hemingway's name
dropping because those names as we are
not rex recognizable to most of us.
Those are just a neighborhood
features, a logo features of one
particular various Paris neighborhoods.
Um,
and those are the things that people
would walk by every day and just take them
for granted.
And that is really what Harris means.
Uh, for Hemingway, he did spend, well for
him. I learned also for Robert Jordan.
Anyway, this spent several years
in Paris. He wrote about it, um,
in a movable feast. Uh, so, and
he, he wrote very well in Paris.
He said he could have stay right about
Michigan best when he was in Paris.
He said that in the
movable fees. Um, so it,
it was Hemingway's home.
Um,
in a sense that is a place
where a writer could write.
And I think that there really is no better
definition of whom home is that as a
place where you can work with ourselves
consciousness where you have a work
routine,
um,
and you can count on being able to produce
something every day. That's for me,
that's also actually my, my own
definition of home. Um, so I'm in,
so it's kind of a minor variation on,
on the Hemingways can total
obsession with writing. Um,
but, um, so it just, you
don't have to think about it.
It's just there every day and you can
just do the same thing every day. Um,
so that is the, it's the security. Um,
and the every day knows our Paris
that is contrasted with the,
um, onsite environment,
which is very violent,
unpredictable where he's
so obviously a foreigner,
even though Hemingway was
so far in, uh, in Paris, um,
the fact that he was able to
write so well in Paris and that,
that as they sue the
foreigners with the racket, um,
by his very, um, productive
relation to his own craft, um,
here, um, this in Spain's a
totally different relations.
So we'll look at what comes after that
invocation in his own mind of Paris that
is brought on by the absence.
Um,
the Gypsy may the face and handed
the cup back is smells of banners,
but it's bitter as gall.
He said it is better to be
safe than have that medicine.
That's the wormwood probably told until
them in this through real absent there
is wormwood is supposed to rot your
brain out. But I don't believe it.
It only changes the ideas.
You should pour water in to it.
Very slowly. A few drops at a time.
But I brought it into the water,
whether you saying hello, said
angrily, feeling the mockery,
explaining the Madison rubbish
and told him in Greenland,
I've bought it in Madrid.
It was the last bottle and
it's lasted me three weeks.
He took a big swallow of it and felt it
coasting over his tone and delicate and
the Stesha in looked at
Pablo and grinned again.
So we've seen how aggressive the low
hosts can be when it comes to hopping on
Kashkin. Right. And you
know, there's four other,
just like Robin ran name debt.
Um,
Ooh, what's the explosive, um,
the aggressions on the logos, um,
is very well matched by when I would say
is to sue the good natured aggression.
But none the less aggression
on the part of Robert.
Um, these people know nothing about Paris
then never have been outside of Spain.
Um, they've never been able to
have the local community. Um,
so it seems that some of them,
many of them have never
been to Madrid even, ah,
because these are the local good drillers.
They have, you know, very much these,
they put in their own small community.
Um,
so even the drip is in many
ways a foreign country to them.
And Rather John in the American, there
was Perez, he knows the capital of Spain.
He knows this liquor they're never tasted,
and he's fooling them into thinking
that this medicine, um, and his mother,
the last bottle of absence and Madrid.
Um,
so all of this, just like
the print illiteracy, um,
the, he comes apart, he just
discovers without meaning to, um,
this is actively highlighting the fact
that he is much more a man of the world
than they are. And there's no
competition, right? I mean,
this is a very well travel man just by
the nature of what he's doing is wild
travel.
Um,
and these people are completely
rooted in their own environment.
Although I should say that
it is an entirely Alton
question by the Anna's novel,
um,
which is the better fair whether it is
the weld travel person who has a better
future or whether it's actually people
who are rooted in the environments who
have a better future. I think it's
very much an open question. Um,
but by the end as an Avo at this moment
though, this is the moment when, uh,
Robert has his law of victory over the
locals are just able to show them all the
things,
highlight dramatized to them other things
that he knows that they don't know.
Um,
so the first location of a distant
home has the effect actually,
uh,
bringing out an edge to say the least.
And Pablo suddenly recognizes that,
um,
and edge attention between Robert and
the locals who otherwise his comrades on
the same side of the war. Um, it
has a funny effect on both sides.
It does something to Robert, it
does something to the locos. Um,
and that's just not even in
America. That's, you know,
Paris is really doesn't have any kind
of special connotation, I don't think,
um, to, to the vocals in a sense that
it, Robert is not really, you know,
um, never consider Frenchmen. Um,
but when it comes to the invocation of
the United States is a different story.
They all know that that's something
that he has a relation to. Um,
and the eye within the progression.
Um, this is the kind of,
we're starting out with the most
benign, uh, most kind of, um,
at least not completely,
not an innocuous invocation of
the United States and businesses.
Most Missoula Montana,
where Robert Jordan it's from and where
he's thinking that he would go back to
after war and that maybe he'll
take them rear, um, with him. Um,
and this is actually a good
moment to think about, you know,
exactly the nature of that Romance
Between Rama, Jordan and Maria.
Why don't marry her sure
that I will marry her.
Then we'll be mister and missus
Robert Jordan of Sun Valley,
Idaho or Corpus Christi is
taxes of Beautiful Montana.
Spanish girls make wonderful wives.
I've never had one. So I know,
and when I get my job back
at a university, she can
be an instructor's wife.
And when undergraduates who take Spanish
four come into smoke pipes in the
evening and have those feel
valuable informal discussions
about Queer Vedo Lope,
Invega Geldof's and other
always admirable debt,
Maria can tell them about
how some of the blue shirt,
the crusaders for the true faith set on
her head while others twisted her arms
and put the skirts up and
stuffed it in her mouth.
Um, it, I began by saying
that this is relatively high,
but if in fact there's no such thing as
benign evocation of a distant home in
Hemingway, it might start out, you
know, even from beginning to end.
Is there's something very funny
about the tone of that invocation.
Um, the first poll of it
is, it's just a kind of, um,
the first little bit of that about
going back to all the cities, you know,
the kind of the heartland of America.
Um,
and then the particular job that he had,
he was a professor at a university.
I'm teaching Spanish. Um, and the
kind of the joke about, you know,
people coming in,
informal discussions best,
I would say that actually it's kind
of a benign or in the sense that, um,
we all tend to be ironic about things
actually that we are quite attached to.
I know this, yesterday I was
talking about a riot as I love, um,
who writes about food and I said, you
know, she's corners just two books out,
one suit. And I said that she
cornered the market on foot writing.
It wasn't as long and they
really looked at me. Um,
but I mean actually love this
author. Um, but that's just my way,
you know, of, of, of not being,
being too attached and you know,
showing some critical distance.
Um, so the first part of their, um,
of, of, of that is just the kinds
of the typical professional RNA. Um,
you know, it was something that you
really actually do want to go back to and,
and, and w, you know, have
some yearning for. Um,
but in the midst of that, um, the,
um,
the Robert just can't stop himself
from importing something else to that
otherwise benign environment.
And so we sort of know ahead of time that
Maria was once rate with no idea when
that happened. Um, is it,
this is Hemingway's way
of telling the story.
I'm giving this and he says of the story,
uh,
one at a time.
So this particular input Asian,
um,
of something that happens in Spain
into an otherwise innocent American
environment has to weigh not only of
darkening the textures of that otherwise
innocent college town,
um,
but also completely changes his
relation to the local setting.
Um, is not even just a place where
he's having trouble with Paolo.
That's the least of the problem.
Um,
they are much more deep rooted problems.
so this is another spin on the idea
of being rooted in your community.
Um, usually when we think of
being rooted in our community, uh,
we just think of, you know, being,
having stayed there for a long time,
maybe having been there for generations,
uh,
or at least within the life of
a person many, many years. Um,
and usually is a good thing.
But this,
another way in which being
rooted in your environment, um,
means that all the dark episodes from
the past are visited upon you all.
A few other oh angers, oh hatreds, um,
are constantly being reactivated
sometimes just in memory and sometimes
reenacted in the bodies of people who
are otherwise young and is very young
girl. Um, but was being visited
upon her is not personal.
It really has nothing to do with her,
is not,
they don't mean to write Maria,
they made raping, verve, um,
as a symbol or something else. So
this is the other, this is hazard of,
um, spending all your life and being
rooted in one particular community.
Um, is that ancient angers, um, can,
uh, can be inherited by, by people
who are relatively young. So,
um,
this,
I will say this is the basic dynamics of
the relation between the United States
and Spain, is that there's a kind
of a spill over in both directions,
um, something very violence spilling
over into the American context. Um,
and then we'll see another way in which
the violence of the American context
will spill over into the
Spanish setting. Um, and um,
this is Ashley.
This is still relatively benign instance.
Um, but again, something
just not quite right.
Um,
yes.
And talking about Gypsies and I was just
say that the Hemingway actually is very,
um, um, uh,
kind of surprisingly,
I'm fascinated about the problem of the
Gypsy even as they're now called Roma
and is a huge problem in the sense
that the year that European Union is
recognizing the fact that the role most
actually have always been oppressed by
various national government. And so
it's a quite a big issue in Europe. Um,
and Hemingway back in the,
in the,
when he was writing about Spanish or
war ready seem to have caught on? Um,
yes. And Samuel said the Gypsies belief
the bearer to be a brother of man.
So also believe the Indians in America,
Robert Jordan said,
and where they kill a bear,
they apologized to him and asked his part.
And do you have any gypsy blood?
No,
but I seen much of them and
clearly seems to movement more.
They are many in the hills to them.
It is not as sin to
kill outside the tribe.
They deny this. But it is
true like the Moore's. Okay.
So it is not as sin to kill
outside tribe usually. I mean,
if most of us, I think no, the in
gelatin is against killing period. Right?
So there's just no qualifying,
no qualify after that.
But according to the Samo,
it is completely okay for the Gypsies
to kill anyone outside of the immediate
tribe. So you know, is a straight, um,
ethnic divide within your own tribe.
You don't kill anyone or you don't cure
anyone unless you are under serious
[inaudible] outside of your tribe,
you're free to kill anyone.
So that's of been crowd
or charge two level, um,
against the Gypsies.
But what is weird is that rather than
comes up with this and Knology is then to
Gypsies. I just liked the morals. Okay.
So this might not make
any sense to us right now,
but it turns out that this is actually
one of aspects of the deep cultural
groups in Spain. Um,
this is a beautiful, um,
instance of the mortgage
architecture in Spain.
You guys know that the
Moore's, um, from Africa,
from North Africa,
um,
Ashley were the rulers
in Spain for 800 years.
It was in 1492 the same year that
Columbus discover the new world.
It was the same year that the Moore's
were expelled from Spain along with Jews.
The more than the Jews were the two
persecuted ethnic groups in Spain.
Um, and so, uh, what,
what Isabella of Castille,
um, expelled the, the,
the, the from Granada, uh, other, um,
there was a, uh, policy,
uh, throughout Spain, um,
to try to erase, um,
Islamic book learning. Um,
Carter above was a huge,
uh,
centered learning throughout the Middle
Ages. Um, and people from all over Europe.
We'd go the call over to study Arabic
science was very, very advanced,
Arabic, more edge architecture was
beautiful. Um, Coloma had bath houses,
more public baths than
any other city in Europe.
It was basically a beacon of enlightenment
in Spain, in, in all of Europe. Um,
and when they were
destroyed by the Catholic,
um, forces by the Catholic monarchs, um,
there was a much of an attempt to try to
erase all of that wasn't as successful.
So we still today if we were to
go to quarterback or two later,
we're still seeing lots of borage
architecture. So there's one kind of,
um,
saw point in Spanish history is that
they really have done this to the very
glorious, that legislation. Um,
but there's another sore point that is
more immediate to the Spanish civil war.
And this is reported by the American
poet most and he was who was there along
with Hemingway.
Um,
and lesson hills was really struck by
the presence of the Morris in the Spanish
civil war.
Um,
so he wrote several pieces
about the Moore's outs,
sometimes seeing them in the hospitals
and actually having this very uneasy
kinship between himself. And
the more, so this is, uh,
from his essay general Franco's Morris
to Morris truths were colonial crimes.
Grips on man from the Moroccan,
the villages and ties into the
army by offers was theme to them.
Very good pay.
Franco's personal body guard
consisted of war as soldiers,
tall picture as fellows and flowing ropes
and winding turbans before I left home
American papers like Harry photographs
of turban or hammered and troops marching
in the streets of Bogos. They'll
am locker and then, you know,
then press dispatched from gelato that
summer and said Arabs having crossing
this trace that you brought Gibraltar
from Spanish Morocco to Algiers theorists
and a locker at a rate of 300,
400 a day.
General Franco intends to mass
50,000 new aerators in Spain.
So given the past history,
given the,
an easy relation between the Spanish,
it's the Spanish and,
and more Asian population of North Africa
for General Franco Ashley to use the
Morris trips as very active combat unit
against the Spanish Republican side that
is about the worst he could have done
was successful. Actually, you know,
he won the war.
Um,
but it was about was in
terms of being Tom Death,
he was probably about as tone deaf as
anyone could be one at the end. Um,
but, um, that's what happened.
And so they were in the loss and loss
of pink lots and lots of pictures of um,
the worst crossing over from Africa,
just paying a five fight
the Spanish republic here,
here's a mortgage bodyguards and um,
the engage in then engage
in more active combat.
Um, so to bring up two more years,
um, I don't even know if it's,
you know, what motivates, um,
Robert to make that analogy
between the GPS and invoice,
it couldn't really be,
um,
just blinders or just carelessness.
I think there's some
intentionality in there,
but it's hard to know why he
would want to bring up this very,
very sensitive issue for the
Spanish. Um, so I think that,
um,
or we can say is that it
seems that it's very easy,
um, for an involuntary, for other, um,
to say something that is wounding to
locals maybe without intending it to have
the extent of the in south
the extended injury. Um,
that is actually the actual outcome
of saying something like that. Um,
Robert probably had no idea that managing
them wars with create those kinds of
connotations. Um, those kinds
of, um, just just as you know,
is um, on the part of this vantage
hearers, but there's, um, what he's doing.
So once again,
it kind of spilling over thinking about
native Americans with their own very
uneasy history in the United States.
Think about the roof Americans thinking
about Gypsy's in Europe and thinking
about the Moore's three ethnic groups,
all with uneasy histories behind them.
And it is the invocation of all three of
them in the same breath that makes that
particular exchange especially,
um, uncomfortable. Um,
if not downright hurtful, but, um,
let's just look at them more serious,
instant, um, incidence of, of,
of this kind of distant home being
the kind of irritation, um, uh, to,
to the immediate environment.
Um,
so also I'll know where Robert Johnson
and they start talking about lynching in
Ohio. Um, this is completely uncalled for.
This is in the context of talking
about the execution of the fascist.
And out of the blue,
Robert just mentioned this lynching
that he was the witness to,
um, and about the trunk and there's
on, they've had them done in it.
So people in general, um, it
is so rubbish on is that, um,
when I was seven years old and going
with my mother to attend a wedding in the
state of Ohio at which I was to be
the boy of a Po boy and girl who carry
flowers. Did you do that?
That Maria, how nice.
In this town and Negro was hand to
a lamppost and they been burned.
It was an arc light, a light which
lower from the post to the pavement.
And he was hoisted first by the mechanism,
which was used to hoist the arc light.
But this broke,
this is a bizarre,
um,
description of lynching to say the least
is stuck in the middle of this long
story about execution of the fascist.
And not only that,
but it seems that much of the focus is
on the mechanism was hoisting this person
up who's about to be,
um,
and on how unreliable this mechanism is,
that it adds to it bricks ones. And then
he was asked to be done over again. So,
um,
what we can say is that this
kind of slightly out of Focus,
um, uh, nature, uh,
to the invocation of the United
States, um, the proper focus,
really odd to be on the
act of lynching yourself.
Anyone telling the story it would have
been on the APP of lynching and instead
it is our focus.
So that's,
it somehow is just focus on the
mechanism of hoisting the person up.
Um, and I think there's
a kind of a deliberate,
Lorraine is there suggest that this is
really how the United States looks, um,
to the Spanish logos that you know,
they can get the focus right if some how
off and that all focus is dramatized by
Maria's response.
We just kind of completely inappropriate
shows the highest degree of ignorance.
Um, well she doesn't know what's coming,
but you know, just to say how nice.
She has no idea. She's completely,
all of it. Doesn't get any of it. Um,
so the reference to the lynching,
my seem out of the blue to us reading
a forum to the belt hosts right now,
but lynching actually was a big issue,
um,
all through the 1930 is um,
even though the actual number of
lynching had declined at that point,
um, it was highlighted. Um,
it was brought to the public
consciousness for a number of reasons. Um,
one is,
um,
this very famous song and I think that
you guys probably have heard Billie
holiday, strange fruit, 1939. Um,
it's a great collaboration between um,
a black singer and actually
the song writer, um,
is um, with Jewish, um,
April Mirror on the wall.
So this is one of the first instances
of a black Jewish collaboration with
having in this class,
like, um, a song, um,
in the jazz repertoire.
But these are the lyrics of strange food
and you can see why it would that image
with lead to those lyrics.
Selling trees,
Bayer strange fruit,
blood on the leaves,
blood at the rude black bodies
swinging in the southern breeze,
strange fruit hanging from
the path of the trees.
Pastoral scene of the gallon self,
the bulging eyes and the
twisting of the sentiment.
Nalliah is Sweden fresh than the
southern smell burning flesh.
Here is a fruit for Lacrosse to blog for
the rain together for the winter stuff.
Stop The Sun to rot from the tree to drop
here is a strange and there's a crap,
um,
the lyrics than Billie holiday was
the one who made the song famous,
but really it was an Abl,
mere Roho that,
that made. The songs are
such a great song. Um,
and I think the power of the song
religious comes from the contrast,
the arch and the rhythm between the kind
of cliche image and the south, you know,
the past road south, um, the Madonna,
Leah, the smell of the Magnolia.
And then the smell of burning flesh
is that alternate rhythm that creates,
generates that peculiar power,
this song.
So that's partly why lynching a was such
an issue on everyone's consciousness in
the 30s. Um, but there were also
other issues and in fact, the song,
um,
it's a great song,
but it's also slightly misleading in
a sense that it's suggesting that's
lynching was strictly a
southern phenomenon, um,
which actually wasn't the case.
Um,
and so all we have to do is to look
at this New Yorker cover about March,
1919 38 for,
I laid really very,
very late for this to be on the
New Yorkers cover. This raises, um,
you know,
just the northern population have been
flabbergasted at how lazy and drunken
blacks are,
um,
because they were migrating
in large numbers to the north.
So I'm relatively new phenomenon
in the 20th century, actually.
Was there, um, substantial
number of lynchings, uh,
both in the north east and
also, um, in the Midwest.
So this is a kind of very famous,
um, lynching, double lynching,
autonomous ship and Aaron
Smith and Indiana in 1938.
So once again, very, very late for
that. Um, and it's because of this, um,
Verizon station or a lynching
was in the north, um,
that the Anaise ACPA, um, Ashley, um,
had this,
um,
regular practice of just hanging up
a flag in the New York City office
announcing that the man was
still lynch yesterday. Um,
and that was also in the 1930s.
Um,
so it was something that
was an ongoing problem, um,
and have very much a kind of, um, uh,
a hot button issue in the 1930s. So, um,
as a consequence of that,
there was an anti lynching bill.
Those trying to make us wait,
uh,
through Congress and the Senate
and it passed in the house. Um,
but because of the filibuster
filibusters buster Senate,
it led to the withdrawal of
the bill in February in 1938.
Um, so, um, it, it, um,
it was just something
that just never went away.
I mean it was an unresolved issue,
um, all the way through the 1930s.
And so having,
we actually was very much plugged into
the politics of the United States when
all of a sudden he would make Ramadan and
suddenly make a reference to lynching.
Um, but just to go back, you know,
move away from that history of lynching
in the United States back to his impact,
um, on the Spanish environment. Um,
the response rear and um, and, and,
and pillar two lynching in
another state is once again,
very art. As I said, when they lifted
the Negro up for the second time,
my mother and pull me away from the
window. So I saw no more children's that.
But since I've had had experiences with
demonstrate the drunkenness is the same
in my country,
it is ugly and brutal.
You and too young as seven, Maria said
you were too young for such things.
I've never seen a negro except in a
circus unless the mowers are Negros.
Some of Negroes and some are not pillows
that I can talk to. You have the morals.
This is mind boggling that this should
be the response to lynching in the United
States.
Um,
we can't even say that it would be
reassuring to say that it's just cultural
ignorance or the impossibility of cross
cultural understanding that is resulting
in the responses from Maria and polite.
It would be nice to be able
to just to say, you know,
it's because they don't know
anything about United States,
but I don't even think that that is the
case. Um, so I would invite you, actually,
this is something to think about.
You know,
why the Spanish always have some weird,
um, and that's putting it mildly.
We're responses to violin to
violence a United States period. Um,
the response to this and never the right
response is always so off focus that
is, you know, it's not even
the wrong response. It's just,
it's just hard to believe that anyone
would respond like that. Um, so, um,
but the, what we see right
there, um, is that this,
once again, we're in vocation of
the Morris in conjunction. Um,
with violence in the United States.
So all we know is that when they
try to make sense of something,
they don't understand.
When the Spanish try to make
sense of something that we
to the more than one. Um,
and the ones who are the people who
come to the mice. Um, so, but it's, is,
is,
is a moment when any kind of community
in between Robert and Marie and color,
any previous can chameleon between
them is completely breaking down.
Um, so I just want to, um,
talk about another episode that has
exactly the same kind of structure of
incomprehension ignorance and income
comprehension on the positive Spanish.
Um, and this has to do with the
Republican Party. You guys remember that?
The leftist in Spain where the Republicans
right there as they're defending the
Spanish republic.
So to be Republican in Spain
means that you are on the left.
And this is the context
for that conversation.
My father was Republican Eyes Live, Maria
Sat, it was for that, that they shot him.
My father was also a Republican, always
live. Also my grandfather Robert,
is that in what country? The United
States, they should them, the mother,
the woman asked Paver,
Maria said,
the United States is the
country of Republicans.
They don't shoot you for being a
Republican. They're all the same.
It is a good thing to have a
grandfather who was a republican.
The woman said it shows a good blood.
My grandfather was on the
Republican National Committee,
Robert Jordan said that impressed even
Maria and it's my father's still active
in the republic polo ass. No, he is.
That can one asks how he died.
He shot himself for
avoiding being tortured.
The woman asked yes,
or I'll visualize them
to avoid being tortured.
So this is where we get that
mix of the comic and the tragic,
it is a comedy of errors so far
for a good part of that passage.
It is accommodated of cross cultural era.
Um,
just not being able to wrap your mind
around the fact that to be a Republican
and now this is a very different thing
being a Republican, um, in Spain.
So just not being able to, you
know, this is just a kind of a,
that the permanent blind there is,
um,
in the mind of Maria and pillow.
So if that was just the case
and it wouldn't go no further,
um, that would just be a
kind of comic, uh, you know,
kind of almost moment with common
relieved, um, in phoned about hose.
Um,
but as is always the case with Hemingway
in this particular novel to comics
certainly morphs into something
else without any warning.
So all of a sudden we get into detail
about Raga Jordan's father shooting
himself too for being tortured.
And that can only have only one
meaning for the Spanish. Um,
it fits completely into the person who
history of Maria, if it's completely, um,
in two philosophy understanding
of political history in Spain. Um,
but right now we don't know why
his father killed himself, uh,
and what kind of torture
he is talking about.
So we have to wait a little longer
to have that mystery clear up for us.
Um,
and to have that mystery clear up,
we actually have to go through
further into the past. So,
um, I've been talking about this 10
homes in terms to some spatial locations,
but this also a distant Tim fro home.
Um,
it turns out that the 19th century is
also unnecessary home for Robert Jordan,
especially the civil war.
It's almost the equivalent
of Paris in terms of psych,
psychological need for
that home. Um, and it,
it's not just any civil war
but his grandfather civil
war and this is his moment
of homecoming. This is the home they
would receive him and shelter him.
Remember something concrete and practical.
Remember grandfather's Sabre,
Right and well oiled in a standard
scabbard and grandfather show you how the
blade had been thin from the many
times it had been to the grinders.
Remember grandfather's Smith and Wesson.
It was the single action officers
model when 32 caliber and there was no
trigger. Got It. Had to softer,
sweetest trigger for you have ever felt.
And there was always,
well oil and boy was clean,
although the finish was all one off and
the bright meadow of the barrel and the
cylinder was one smooth from
the letter of the host or, um,
so this is like Hemingway's
description of the trout fishing, um,
in in our time, very, very clear the
smoothness cleaners of their operation.
Um, but in this particular context, um,
the smoothness and the cleaners
and the one alumnis, uh,
of that pistol suggest that
this is a well used weapon. Uh,
Robert Jordan [inaudible] grandfather
was a hero of the civil war. Um,
his favor had been to the grinders
numerous times because it has been this,
the provide had been so well used.
So without saying anything,
without using the word glory or heroic,
any comparable adjective,
um, Hemingway gives us the,
um,
the sense that the civil war was the
heroic moment was the high point in the
history of Robert's family.
And it was very much
vested in his grandfather.
And at that point it has receded.
It has to,
it has to be received into the past
is belongs to the 19th century.
But Roger that wants to activate it over
and over again bring it up to the 20th
century because he needs that and we know
why he needs to bring the 19th century
back on the next page when we
know what happens to that pistol.
Then after your father has shot himself
with a pistol and you had come home from
school and they had a funeral,
Ricardo had returned it
after the inquest thing. Bob,
I guess you might want to keep
the gun. Um, he climbed. Okay.
I should just stop and clarify. That is
something we'll be talking about. Um,
Ashley, the narrative switches from
second person Pronoun, rubber Jordan,
interesting himself as to you.
So that's you is rubber Jordan.
And then it switches back to the person.
He climbed out on a rock and leaned
over and saw his face and there's still
water and saw himself holding
the gun and that he dropped it,
holding it by the muscle.
And so I'd go down making bubbles until
it was just as big as a wash charm in
the clear water.
And then it was all the site.
So this passage that comes
just on the opposite page,
um,
from the previous evocation
of the civil war weapons,
the grandfather tells us exactly why
the 19th century in the civil war is
unnecessary emotional shelter for Robin.
He's just so ashamed of his father.
Um,
he wants to clean out that entire episode,
drop it into the clear water so
that it will be completely outside.
Um, he can do that too. The pistol,
he can do it to the
actual history is that,
but that's as close as he can
get to wiping out that history.
Um, and so in this moment, Ashley, uh,
there is no Spanish environment that
is invoked and I think that this is no
mention of the immediate Spanish setting
and I think that that is suggestive as
well. Um, in the sense that
really the homes for Robert,
I think, um, and it's a very
pessimistic reading of the novel.
Uh, they basically just two
homes. Robert. One is the Paris,
um, of the, um,
evening papers and the chestnut trees
and out the other home for him is a home
that never was a home
that was in his lifetime,
but the home that he can inherit
vicariously through his grandfather.
And that is the American civil
war as his spiritual home,
because this is the one place where he
has affirmation of himself that he's not
ashamed of himself, not ashamed
of his family history. Um,
and so those are impossible
Homans for them at this spoon.